In the US, President Donald Trump's former associate Paul Manafort...
...was found guilty on eight counts of fraud,...
...while associate Michael Cohen pleaded guilty to eight crimes and blamed Trump,...
...who denies involvement.
An earthquake with a 7.3 magnitude struck the northern coast of Venezuela...
...and hit buildings as far away as the capital, Caracas.
Iran announced its intentions to boost its military power...
...and presented a new fighter jet...
...amid growing tensions with the US and other countries...
...over conflicts in the Middle East.
In India, the Indian government has asked the WhatsApp mobile device service...
...to develop a way to track messages so that rumors can be shut down...
...because they have led to many wrongful killings in the past year.
Finally in North Korea, South Korean families became emotional...
...as they said their goodbyes to loved ones living in North Korea.